In this problem, a radiation monitor is
placed along a straight line between two
sealed steel drums containing
radioactive waste.
Each drum has a diameter of 2 ft.
Drum A produces a radiation intensity of
80 mR per hour at its surface and is
located 4 ft center to monitor from the
monitor.
Drum B produces a radiation intensity of
180 mR per hour at its surface
and is located on the opposite side of
the monitor at an unknown distance
center to monitor.
If the total radiation measured at the
monitor is 10 mR per hour,
what is the distance in feet from the
centers of drum A and drum B?
Okay, so first let's sketch this problem
out in case you are having difficulty
understanding the problem statement.
Here we have our extremely advanced
radiation sensor.
Over to the left will be drum A.
Over to the right will be drum B.
The statement notes that drum A produces
a radiation intensity of 80 mR per hour
and is located 4 ft away from the sensor
from the center of the barrel.
And we've been told as well that the
drums have a diameter of 2 ft, so a
radius of 1 ft.
The radiation at drum B is 180 mR per
hour, but we don't know the distance
away from the monitor.
Finally, we are given the radiation
measurement at the monitor as 10 mR per
hour.
And we are being asked to find the total
distance between the centers of both
drums.
So, if we first search for the word
radiation in the reference manual, we
will eventually get to a section about
the inverse square law.
It is written as follows.
Intensity 1 over intensity 2 equals the
square of radius 2 over the square of
radius 1.
So, this is the only equation we need to
solve this problem.
Let's do it in steps.
First, we will find just the radiation
contribution from drum A.
So, intensity 1 is going to be the drum
and that's 80 mR an hour.
And intensity 2 is going to be unknown
because we just want to find
specifically drum A's contribution.
The radius
of 2 is 4 ft
and the radius of the drum is going to
be 1 ft.
So, solving this out,
we can see that we get 80 over 16 or
5 mR per hour.
Now, we can subtract that from the total
measured at the sensor to find drum B's
radiation contribution as well.
So, 10 minus 5 is going to be 5 mR per
hour
coming from drum B.
Setting up the inverse square law
equation again,
we can say that intensity 1 this time
will be the
radiation from drum B
and intensity 2 will be the radiation
measured at the sensor. The radius 2 is
going to be the radius from the sensor
to the drum,
which is unknown.
And radius 1 is again going to be the
radius of the drum.
So, if we solve this out, we can see
that our total distance between the
sensor and the drum is going to be 6 ft.
That means that step three, all we have
to do
is sum the distance from drum A to the
sensor and drum B to the sensor or 4 + 6
to give us a final answer of 10 ft.
So, this is one of those problems
where understanding the concept is
really important because you need to
recognize that you need to solve for
drum A's contribution first
even though the total radiation at the
sensor is already given.
If you can figure that step out,
obviously the math here is super easy
and there's only three steps.
And that's it.